meanwhile turning overseas u.s is not
alone in its fight against the omicron
variant cases have now been reported in
at least 19 other countries or
territories all around the world
including south africa where the strain
was first identified and that's where we
find our deborah patta who's been
spending time with scientists they're
doing absolutely crucial research into
the origins of this strain and they've
already learned a lot
this is ground zero for omicron
scientists in this high-risk biohazard
lab arm themselves for another day on
the covert battlefront they are hot on
the trail of the new mutant strain
circling the globe z i'm coming to give
you a cryo box from the freezer here
they are growing live omicron which will
be tested against the blood of fully
vaccinated people as well as those who
were previously infected heading up this
team at the africa health research
institute is virologist alex seagal this
is probably the most mutated virus
we've ever seen the variant has more
than 50 mutations over 30 in the spike
protein making it easier to attach
itself to human cells it's more of a
frankenstein than others but it's always
something new i mean the virus keeps
surprising us now they are collaborating
with other scientists to determine if
the variant blunts vaccine immunity this
lab has received multiple requests for
samples of omicron which are being
packed to be shipped off to other
research institutes around the country
infectious disease expert richard
lessels works next door at the
sequencing lab that helped identify the
new variant and is studying the spread
of omicron in real time
what's critical now over the next week
or two is to
really
see in the data what the pattern is
there is there
an increasing rate of infections in the
vaccinated
and what is the severity of disease in
those individuals
seagal believes omicron has been
clocking up evolutionary changes for
well over six months now by lurking in
an immune compromised person who was
unable to clear a covered infection he
warns as long as africa lags behind in
vaccinations this won't be the last
mutation we're going to learn together
the rest of the greek alphabet
unless we understand
why these variants evolve how they
evolve and be able to predict them
there's been an uptick in infections
amongst young people in south africa but
these scientists are confident that
existing vaccines will protect against
serious illness and hospitalization
they'll have those answers in less than
10 days nate
deborah powder thank you